i got really obsessed with like the
terry cloth lifestyle like i wanted to
have clothes made out of terry cloth
like everything that i did like made it
i had i asked for a suit made out of
cherry cloth it'd just be like the beach
lifestyle i love terry harry calls me
well my hands get sweaty so i love
towels yeah dude oh my gosh she's like
your brother
like you i have the worst sweaty hands
yeah that's right because it's your
brother too have you looked into it
surgery i so i just got like i'm not a
i'm not a medication type person like i
just got this medication to try i tried
it yesterday and it made me freezing i
was like now i'm shivering and i'm like
i don't want to [ __ ] feel cold either
like but your hands aren't sweaty i
looked into having the surgery to get
like my sweat gland removed from my
armpit but then i didn't want to start
sweating somewhere else
i know that's it one of those
no one of the side effects i remember it
said it's a
possible sweat in the back of your uh
thighs yeah and you're just dripping
sweat because it has to go somewhere
yeah i'm like i'd rather sweat from like
normal places than yeah i just started
yeah exactly but i get sweaty hands and
sweaty feet and so like even sandals
that have that like kind of terry cloth
material like i love that
for sure i used to like you know and
like scott and i go to these gatherings
right where like after the gathering
everybody like holds hands and says a
prayer
and scott like gets really really like
dudes thinks i'm like
i got eight years sober people think i'm
like detoxing off coke because i've been
dripping sweating oh like even on the
mike tyson podcast she was like what's
up and
i shook hands and you just see him going
like this
and i can't stop thinking about it like
it's like it's like yeah it's really
annoying everybody everybody holds hands
and feels god's hand on your back
it drives me crazy like i don't even
like to hold him like in a relationship
they're like my ex-boyfriend who like
he's still like probably texted me an
hour ago and he like is
won't get over me but um he broke up
with you because your sweaty hands like
hold my hand i'm like i don't want to my
hands when he's like i don't care and
i'm like i do like it's like i don't
like the feeling like holding your hand
while my hands like sweaty it's like
it's weird you know yes you have like
lotion you put lotion on your body like
it's just a weird like slime i don't put
lotion on my hands or feet and then i
actually feel like i'm like great now my
hands are starting to look like they're
80 because i never put lotion on them so
they're like starting to look cold yeah
so like what what i do now like before i
go to bed is i'll like put lotion on the
outside and like go like that really
your feet sweat too because mine dripped
yeah my feet my hands went so bad and
like i told um
no i told my doctor i was like you
understand i was like i i get excited to
wear sandals in the winter like i do
literally like in the winter i get more
like into sandals or
heels and then in the summer i'm like i
was like why are you always in sneakers
i'm like
because i don't feel like slipping
everywhere all day like
i want to just be able to walk you know
do you think that two people who know
each other have super sweaty hands would
like
to be okay holding hands they just put
each other's hands in their pockets like
i'll put it in her pocket she'll put it
[Laughter]
yeah like or like i used to be stoked
like at a bar like playing pool because
they used to have the powder and i'm
like just constantly putting powder all
the pants and then they were leather and
they and they were sticking to him and
so i forgot which it was ross and one of
those like put some powder and then he
puts the powder like to try and stop
like from sweating and like not being
able to and then he's like it's turning
into paste
yeah exactly
exactly dude
people don't understand the struggle of
sweaty hands yeah it is bad i wonder why
i said that your brother your brother
has sweaty hands too though we both have
sweaty hands so you said you've been
sober though and you still have sweaty
hands yeah okay because i thought for a
while it's gotten a little better but
i'm just like like
i have the softest man hands and it's
like because my hands sweat so much and
so it's like
you know some girls find like rough
hands you know sexy on a man because
it's like wow this guy's like doing
construction
i have like the softest hands ever known
to man and like it's kind of you know
i'm pretty sure that most girls don't
find a guy doing construction sexy
no i mean like you know you can like
build [ __ ] and like dude right right and
it's like they're just like callous
tanned like hi i'm a man nice to meet
you right your hand just slips right
outside
i've never like like i've never been
like oh like this is a rough hand like
he he must be like you know but i have
noticed the other way like he has really
soft hair oh my god
you think oh man he's a [ __ ] yeah
it's the same thing
what a [ __ ]
what a bitch-ass [ __ ] this guy is dude
no but that's crazy though because i
thought um i do notice that when i don't
drink sweat way less yeah and then um
the weird thing is like i've i mean i've
been smoking and grew up in l.a i've
been smoking weed since i was like 12.
and you have weed businesses too yes
yeah yeah well i i don't want to talk
about that yet but yeah yeah okay um but
uh but yeah i thought that sometimes too
like i need to smoke because sometimes
i'll be like like hot water and then i
smoke and then i completely stop and i'm
like is this a problem that developed
from like smoking weed or something you
know no it's probably just like an
anxiety issue yeah but you know i i
notice it's dropped 80 percent you know
but i used to be [ __ ]
dropped 80 since when since like getting
getting set
he's like you used to be he's like used
to be sweatier
it's bad like it was really bad we're
like like i would just like give
knuckles like in the 90s before knuckles
were like you know pre-pandemic it's
like people like oh what's up and
they're like damn dude like what's up
bro it's a wet nook
it's a wet nut
yeah dude that's my rap name wet nut wet
neck you like hug people they're like
drowning
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats